People are building silverquill wrong.
I'm not saying those other lists are
bad.
Actually, quite the opposite. They're
probably really freaking good. I mean,
tokens and big spells, you can't go
wrong with those. But that's what they
are, just token decks and big spell
decks. And if that's what you're looking
for, I'm sure they can do a solid job,
but they're not silverquill decks. Also
worth mentioning in the same cycle,
there happens to be arguably a better
spells commander, and witherbloom is
probably better for tokens. The colors
is a bit rough, but the mechanic is so
perfect for the spells and tokens
archetype that a lot of people are doing
with silverquill. But yeah, this is how
I've learned to define best in EDH. The
strategy that this particular commander
enables better than anyone else.
Shorikai, for example, is a really
powerful blue white control commander,
but is that really a Shorikai deck?
Meanwhile, if you play vehicles, it
might not be quite as strong, but it
does have a much better identity that is
built around the commander. Okay, back
to silverquill. Big spells seems to be
the popular way, except Orzhov doesn't
have that many big spells and the deck
seems really fragile. The moment our
dragon gets dealt with, it becomes two
separate piles with barely any synergy.
Yeah, so silverquill is about the
interaction between spells and
creatures. It wants creatures and it
wants spells and wants something that
unites creatures and spells, spells and
creatures, spells and sacrifice, all
that together. Oh, if you came from my
last video of Skriff, you might have a
bit of an idea. Honestly, I'm not sure
why I'm doing this again, maybe because
I just happen to be in that headspace,
or it's some kind of unhealthy
obsession. It's probably the latter, but
anyways, here you go. This is the plan.
Yes, these undying draft chaffs again,
but this time with a little twist
because I've always noticed among the
recurring black last picks, there are
two piles of spells that kind of
synergize well with each other. You
know, combining these with these, I can
turn three cards into three cards for
the low low cost of a bunch of mana.
Doesn't feel like the most efficient
play, but now imagine something like
this with silverquill on the board.
Honestly, it's kind of complicated. I
goldfish the deck over and over again,
and it didn't help. Let's work it out
together. Okay, first I cast undying
evil, I'll copy it by sacrificing our
little helper here and give undying to
our solemn and your gym ball. And next
up, we costly plunder the solemn and
casualty the your gym ball to copy that.
These both come back and we draw four
cards. And of course, the dying and ETB
trigger from solemn. That seems decent,
and we get more gas to keep going with
different creatures, too. I mean, it's
by no means broken, but silver is the
only commander that makes something like
this possible. So, why don't we give it
a shot? I mean, it's only $90, not even
half a tank of gas nowadays. And did you
know that with this deck, you can save
100% on gas because you won't be invited
to go anywhere anymore? Okay, more on
the synergies and inner workings later,
but let's start by introducing our
chaffs. So, the secret to budget deck is
a a big column of draft chaff. And here
we have two. Let's start with the
undying ones. We're playing with 13 of
them, all slightly different. Oh, you
know what? We should make a tier list.
Well, let's take a look at this one. Two
mana plus two plus zero, that is awful.
My guys aren't even dying to combat.
Take your own death, also plus two, but
getting a treasure is really good. It's
as good as it gets here. So,
uh what do I need death touch for? I
guess surprise combat trick. Am I chump
blocker? Yeah, it's still crap. Crap.
Ooh, lifelink. Crap. Look, we have an
uncommon carrying the bunch. Let's see,
suspect. Crap. Hold up, what is this? We
got M&M over here. Yeah, this is like
the OG undying effect. We got to respect
the OG, right? Just kidding, it's crap.
Okay, less crap are these one mana ones.
Undying evil, feign death, supernatural
stamina. Now, all the undying effects
are awful magic cards in a vacuum, yes,
but there is a tier S option, but we
can't afford it. Where's my reprint? I
swear they're going to save these till
return to return to Zendikar and milk
those special guest slots. But anyways,
on a brighter note, let's take a look at
our cannibalism themed package here.
Also a tier list, but this time with a
bit more variance. Altar of reap is the
base effect. The ones coming after are
usually tagged with some set mechanics,
so yeah, this one is pretty bad, but the
option to sack artifacts is nice here in
a pinch, but not that much of a boost.
Map token, that's like, yeah, the worst
set mechanic, almost as bad as mutagen.
Treasure, okay, that's what I'm talking
about. These ones are amazing when
copied, which they will be. Straight to
tier A. Eviscerator's insight, okay,
this one is solid. The flashback is very
useful in the late game. Nasty end has a
decent upside. We can definitely sack
our commander if there's no better
option and draw six when copied.
Lifegain is cool, but nothing to write
home about. Plumb the forbidden is
interesting. Normally, this is like the
best of the bunch, but in this deck,
it's slightly more complicated because
when copied with casualty, we only get
to draw one extra card with this, rather
than two or three. But it does have a
higher ceiling. It can go off with stuff
like Professor Onyx, so there it goes.
And the one mana ones, once again, are
some of the best. Sure, the ceiling
isn't quite as high as the treasure
making ones, but these are twice as
likely to keep mana open for. And when
your deck has a mix of instant and
sorcery speed stuff, this is a very big
deal. And some of the crappier ones show
how low we're willing to go just to get
a lot of these effects. Three mana,
sure, no problem. Sorcery speed, okay,
I'll take it. And uh morbid curiosity,
yeah, this one is not like not crap. I
guess there's some potential, like we
can sacrifice our commander for four
cards, which becomes eight when copied.
That's good, but
no, not really.
Finally, tier S, we have Midgard. I
mean, the spell is awful, so it might be
a bit contentious, but being on a land
is just such a massive upside. I mean,
if there's no limit to how many of these
I can play, I would probably replace at
least five lands, maybe five of these
with Midgard. And guess what?
Congratulations, now you have two very
useless tier lists. Screenshot these,
not for EDH reasons, but it's like a
mental wellness check. If one day while
building a deck, you're like, "Ooh, I
remember that tier list of common
undying effects, I should check it."
Get help, or double down and start a
YouTube channel. And here is the core
engine of the deck. This part remains
fixed along with the commander. We make
very little change here, no matter who
we play against. Even the full budget
version plays pretty much the same list
of chaff here. Next part is fun, though,
because we have a toolbox of creature
cards, and those you can adjust however
you want, depending on your meta and
your budget. Just keep the meta curve in
mind. Don't go too crazy with big dumb
idiots. Also make sure you have some of
these fodders. These are really useful
for getting the first undying effect
copied to start our value train. So,
let's start with the fodders, the cat,
the dog, the vampire, the consumer, and
this unlucky wizard, I guess. Chittering
witch and company commander are some of
the best token creators, bringing us
four bodies for four mana. Callous
bloodmage is excellent. I find that each
mode is chosen around 50% of the time
when I play the deck. That's the sign of
a modal spell being a great fit. A few
of these just in case we miss our land
drops or someone goes nuts with ramp.
Unless that someone is us, because
solemn is a great card pretty much
anywhere, but in this deck, it's
actually one of the best creatures to
kill over and over again. Make sure to
use this art for the why me again vibes.
Some edict effects and the chupacabra
but chup copy
this thing to deal with the creature
decks. Skyclave apparition deals with a
massive range of problems, and I'm a big
fan of your gym ball. Both chapters one
and two are immensely useful, and we can
reset it over and over again.
Flickerwisp has a lot of flexibility. It
can be used defensively or for value.
Blinking our ETB effects is nice, but
the reason it makes the cut is for
protecting our commander or other key
pieces when something like a farewell
inevitably comes. Another safety valve
is even interrupter. Having this in your
hand or on the board just makes passing
the turn feel so much safer. Gray
merchant is our win condition. This deck
does have problem with closing games.
Kokushou is $20, so gray merchant will
do, and it's more than sufficient. Just
a few blinks should crumble your
opponent's life total and their world
will continue. Some of the other more
expensive utility creatures include
puppeteer clique and chunge. These are
just my favorites at the moment. You can
putting pretty much anything. I also did
draft up a non-budget version, though.
I'll cover that later in the video. Some
of the upgrades are pretty sweet. But
yeah, that wraps up our toolbox package.
We should also have a few enablers aside
from the commander itself. These can
cost a little more, but they really can
turn our game actions into mini value
explosions. First of all, at $3, we have
luminous broodmoth. We do have a few
flyers, but not too many. Unfortunately,
our commander is one of them, but but
this is still really good. It's like a
mini Mikaeus that doesn't combo. Next up
is Sedgemoor witch. With this, we'll
never run out of fodders, and it will
even accumulate a small army to swarm
our opponents with. And finally,
Professor Onyx. Honestly, I'm not sure
this is the best card to spend money on,
but it's just it feels so fitting. I
mean, it comes in, wrecks our opponent's
board, and if it sticks, every time we
do our badabing badaboom, we drain each
opponent for eight life. That seems
decent. Okay, and just the last bit of
wrap-up, the cards will flow in this
deck as soon as we set up our engine, so
it will be difficult to run out of gas.
So, because of that, we do need a decent
chunk of ramp. We are prioritizing two
drop mana rocks
because these are much easier to weave
in between our actual value plays. The
only three cost ones I play here are
Bender's water skin and relic of
legends. It's very likely that we'll use
the water skin's four mana per gold
round fully, and relic can potentially
top for more than that if we start to
loop some legendary creatures. Okay,
onto the lands. Aside from mana fixing,
we prioritize these ones that make
tokens. A few budget MDFCs, and that's a
wrap. And there's the deck. The
Christmas land board state does take a
little bit to set up. You need your
commander, two creatures with strong
ETB, and another fodder, either token or
doggle. But what's nice about a deck
like this is your early game is also
filled with action. You get these cheap
ETB creatures to answer things, and all
of these cards pretty much have cycling
as long as you get them in pairs. We dig
for lands and ramp and work our way into
the mid game. Once we have a decent
board, we drop silverquill and live
life.
Speaking of living life, say, "What if
we have a little more budget? What are
some upgrades we can look at?" Well,
I've also included a full budget list
down below, but there's a lot of good
stuff. The first card I would splurge on
is without question Kokushou. Yeah,
actually, I would suggest proxying the
commander and spend that $20 on this
because we definitely need win
conditions, and dropping Kokushou along
with our commander will end the game
fast. Second place is a bit closer, but
probably probably Mikaeus. Yeah, I'm
sure you've heard of him. Even though I
can't think of any infinite combos in
this deck, my queue will probably find
one anyways. Following that, I also want
to try Sephora. Flipping him will be
really easy and with enough resources,
we can actually bring him back, flip him
over and over. With a lack of win
conditions having two of these emblems
will completely change our game.
For utility creatures, recruiter of the
guard is something we'd want to sack
over and over again. Shieldred is
expensive, but the edict effect is so
good and the backside can also win
games. Also, Sedecy is crazy value.
Aside from these, the upgrades become
more diminishing returns actually.
Actually, Cauldron Haze is a card I've
been wanting to use for a long time and
it seems great here. Some of these MDFCs
can do a lot of work and winding canyons
is a personal favorite. But yeah, I
imagine this to be an excellent deck for
starting with a budget shell and then
working your way up. Every bomb you
acquire along the way will make a great
difference. The deck is very resilient
to disruption. We can easily rebuild
after board wipes, but this is actually
one of the higher complexity decks I've
built. There's a lot of decision making
and triggers to stacking and sometimes
you just have to cycle these cards
before the commander comes out just to
keep the train rolling. But it's also
possible to run out, so there's a lot of
resource management here. And also, this
is a new commander, so I haven't had too
much time to play test, but if you do
end up building it, please let me know
how it goes. Or do you know any other
sweet Silver
Goad decks? Also, leave a comment. This
is Jin with